congratulations we've reached a
branching point in our lesson now a few
different ideas have been introduced so
it's important to orient ourselves here
before moving forward in various
directions now what motivated this
lesson well we learned about RSA
encryption and RSA depended on two
things one that prime factorization is
difficult so if I multiply two big
crimes together p1 and p2 and I give you
an I can trust or feel secure in knowing
that you'll take a long time to find
those Prime's and maybe more than your
lifetime also to RSA requires that those
large primes I generated was easy
meaning I could just quickly generate a
large prime
so let's return to the first problem
difficulty of prime factorization well
what is it about prime factorization or
just prime numbers themselves which make
problems hard and to find out we began
with the core problem given X is x prime
or composite which is a prime ality test
now we ended up building some solutions
to this problem and in doing so we
realize that this problem was
computationally expensive that is there
was no instant solution to this problem
as our input number grew the amount of
time or the amount of steps involved for
our algorithm to find the solution also
grew and how much it grew we actually
understand better now because we can
predict this search space using the
prime number theorem though the real
issue can be thought of as a graph where
on the vertical axis we have the number
of steps our algorithm takes so you can
just think of it as time and on the
x-axis is the input size and as input
size increased so did time and the
problem we had is that the shape of this
curve is unacceptable because in our
case once n hit even 20 digits we can no
longer solve the problem in the worst
case and if we threw an input hundreds
of digits long at our algorithm we can
all agree it would not work in our case
it would crash so it's practically
impossible to check if large input is
prime using our current strategies now
let's return to the first point
factorization realize based on our
current understanding in this lesson
factorization has to be harder than a
prime ality test
that is there are more steps involved in
finding the prime factorization of some
number versus just telling me if a
number is prime since remember
factorization requires us to find all
the prime factors for some input n
whereas a prime ality test only requires
that we find one divisor
and a nice reminder of this is that some
users have actually turned these prime
ality tests into prime factorization
algorithms simply by repeating after it
finds its first divisor so the primary
test is just kind of a subroutine inside
the main factorization algorithm
so if we return to this graph a
factorization algorithm would be
something like this as input grows our
factorization algorithm would be above
this prime ality test line and realize
that in any situation we always have a
computational limit that is the number
of primitive steps we can calculate
which is based on our computer power
computing power in any given situation
and the amount of time we had and you
could think of this as a horizontal line
or a threshold on this graph anything
above this line is out of reach not
feasible to solve and in this lesson we
were limited by the rover's on-board
computer which was fairly slow which is
why we couldn't run prime ality tests i
on numbers with even 20 digits however
even if we had say a thousand computers
running for a year this would simply
just push this horizontal line up to
some other threshold and this would
allow us to run tests on larger numbers
but as you can see we would always hit
some limit where the input is large
enough that we can no longer solve the
problems again
now this leads to many interesting
question paths however all identify the
two I'm going to explore next first of
all so far I have not been very precise
about these growth curves though it
would be helpful if imagine for any
algorithm you give me no matter what
it's trying to solve and no matter what
machine it's even running on we could
draw some corresponding growth curve on
this graph simply by looking at the
description of the algorithm if we could
do this we could identify categories of
certain growth shapes which tell us how
difficult a problem will be to solve and
in this way we could understand an
algorithm before we even run it but very
important to think about and I could you
could hand me your algorithm written on
a piece of paper and I could look at it
and i'll say i know this algorithm is
not solvable with the input size needed
and this leads us to a lesson on time
complexity an incredibly important
conceptual tool we will need and if
you've ever heard oh this runs in
polynomial time or exponential time
these are terms which come out of time
complexity next many of you have been
wondering well how are we generating
these random primes and practice that
second point I made about our essay well
let's just walk through it quickly to
generate a large random prime number
hundreds of digits long we need to
follow these instructions generate a
random number
test if its prime if its prime we're
done if not try again until we hit a
prime now in this three-step procedure
what's most important is the second step
test if it's prime if we can't do that
step this won't work so how is this
working today well it's based on a
subtle alteration to our problem
definition and more importantly the use
of randomness and this leads us to
another lesson on random algorithms and
now finally if there are any other
lingering question paths you have please
post them below and we can plan lessons
for example there are some deeper
mathematics we have yet to explore in
order to speed up our existing trial
division prime allottee tests and what
else are you thinking of please share
below